Freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
besonderen Video alle Einkäufe die hier
seht kommen in einem Drei-Gänge-Menü auf
unter 10 Euro pro Person und ich sage
nur so viel wenn ich das alleine machen
würde wird es vielleicht nicht so gut
werden wie wenn ich das mit diesem Mann
hier an meiner Seite tun würde max
Lorenz schön Dich hier begrüßen zu
dürfen endlich bei mir in der neuen
Küche was sagst du abgesehen davon dass
ich euch alle hier wieder sehe großartig
und die Küche ist super geworden mega
geil ja und Max Lorenz ist nicht nur
unfassbar freundlich sympathisch gut
aussehen und attraktiv sondern hat auch
ein bisschen Lautstärke das ist
natürlich eine Sache die sehr bewundere
und das heißt auch folglich dass Du
extrem gut kochen kannst deshalb für
heute behilflich sein wirst bei diesem
wunderbaren Menü oder genau also Titel
war ja wir kochen pro Person für unter
10 € und dann schon ein bisschen was mit
Anspruch als jetzt nicht irgendwie eine
Spaghetti Bolognese die auch super
lecker ist und dann vielleicht eine
Milchreis kann er auch oder vorweg
machen alles cool irgendwie
Challenge gegeben und ich habe dann
einfach mal die gestern kurz per
WhatsApp geschrieben sowas brauchen wir
habe ich das erstmal den Preis
eingehalten ja du hast ihn eingehalten
das muss ich vorab sagen es sind bei
manchen Sachen also wenn man alles alles
neu kauft was wir heute benutzen auch
Zucker Salz Pfeffer dann kommt man über
10 Euro pro Person aber bei den Sachen
die wir tatsächlich benutzen landen wir
bei unter 10 € pro Person deshalb ihr
werdet immer die Preise eingeblendet
sehen wenn wir irgendwas verwenden es
ist wirklich wahr und ich bin überrascht
weil das was am Ende wirklich auf der
auf der Speisekarte steht klingt nach
viel mehr wenn du mich fragst wir machen
heute zur Vorspeise eine knusprige
Bruschetta mit einem im Ofen gegarten
Hokkaido Kürbis einer cremigen burata
und eingelegten roten Zwiebeln Mama mir
im Hauptgang machen wir ein schönes
Lachsfilet mit einem cremigen Gemüse
Risotto mariniert zum Rucola und
gerösteten walnusskern und im Dessert
ich habe gesehen Du magst es ein
schokoladenauflauf mit flüssigen Kern
und dazu eine Soße von weißer Schokolade
und Apfel mama mia also wirklich ich
finde es klingt vielleicht noch den ein
oder anderen politischen Namen
einstreuen würdest also was heißt Brühe
auf Französisch mit dem Gemüse
nee also es ist wirklich wahnsinnig
glaube wir werden viel lernen heute
lasst uns anfangen ist super ich würde
sagen du fängst an mit dem Kürbis schon
mal so etwas wir werden ungefähr so ein
ja so maximalen Viertel Kürbis brauchen
einfach Vierteln also ich Viertel den
hier mal und hole dann die Kerne genau
Ofen 160 Grad vorgeheiztes Umluft
einfach laufen lassen und ich komme ich
in der Zeit schon mal für das Gemüse
Risotto können wir quasi jetzt sozusagen
ja es gab ja mal diesen Begriff notes to
tail also vom Tier quasi alles
verarbeiten kann man ja auch beim Gemüse
also muss ja nicht die Schale
wegschmeißen und dann irgendwie so ein
gekörnten Mist holen und dann kannst du
einfach quasi die ganze Schale die bei
so einem Suppengrün immer da ist einfach
nehmen rauskochen hast dann quasi direkt
den Geschmack drin also noch einmal
Viertel ein bisschen Öl bisschen Salz
Pfeffer kannst du gerne mit rein tun und
du willst kannst auch schon mal ein zwei
Thymian Zweige damit mit drauflegen wenn
du den Ofen schiebst das jetzt aber wenn
wir jetzt kein frischen Typen hat kann
man auch getrocknet nehmen wenn man hat
Oregano zu Hause also schon irgendwie
was was ein bisschen Wumms dahinter hat
wenn jemand sagt oh bei mir auf dem
Balkon wächst mega Seilbahn ich liebe
Salbei nimm Salbei viel Freak bei mir
sind die nächsten Schritte ich quasi das
Gemüse vorbereitet fürs Risotto ich hier
schneit das einfach so ein bisschen
runter dass wir wenn wir quasi nachher
den Reis anschwitzen direkt das Gemüse
mitzugeben können und das quasi mit
unserer heißen Brühe die wir jetzt
selber kochen auffüllen Max äh schickt
es gleich den Kürbis in Ofen und wird
sich dann gleich einmal um die
eingelegte Zwiebel kümmern auch hier
klar eine einzelne rote Zwiebel kriegt
man vielleicht einen unverpackladen aber
ihr habt den Preis eingeblendet gesehen
so kann man sie kaufen man kauft
wahrscheinlich im Netz hat ein bisschen
was übrig ist dann halt so und was man
ja auch sagen muss bei dem was wir
kochen heute für zwei Portion das ist
auch schon von den Mengen her für zwei
Personen sehr sehr gut abgemessen also
wenn es jetzt
einen dabei der ist nicht so viel dann
kriegt man damit wahrscheinlich auch
drei satt ja ja jetzt quasi
Gemüseschalen auch hier noch den Rest
von der Zwiebel mit rein Gemüsebrühe
machen wir an Gemüse haben wir
geschnitten Karotte Sellerie Porree
Blumenkohl Eis Zwiebeln hast du ganz
toll geschnitten großartig also danke du
könntest jetzt anfangen zu den einzelnen
das heißt wir brauchen ein bisschen
Essig ja einfach einfach mit rein
der billige das kann auch Weißweinessig
sein also das ist jetzt wirklich da muss
man keine um für ausgeben kleine Idee
Zucker mit rein du kannst ruhig einmal
aufkochen lassen und zwei
Rosmarin wenn du da hast auch wenn nicht
geht das auch alles getrocknet also da
muss man da muss man sich mal ein
bisschen von freimachen dass man immer
nur frische Sachen da haben muss jetzt
werden die Zwiebeln schon so rosa
richtig richtig die Säure passiert das
gerade ich dachte immer dass das so nach
fünf Monaten einlegen erst kommen
die einfach hier ein bisschen ziehen und
fertig und dann haben wir quasi nachher
so leicht süße Säure bisschen
mediterrane Kräuter drin dann werden wir
die mit so einer Pinzette platzieren und
jeder wird bereits sein ist sehr viel
Geld für uns ausgegangen
Gemüsebrühe vor sich hinzieht er können
uns in den schokoladenauflauf kümmern
flüssigen Thema Wasserbad nee
Gemüsebrühen
schmilzen wir die Schokolade aber man
kann auch sagen energiemäßig ja klar
gerade aktuell ein sehr großer
Kostenfaktor auf jeden Fall ne ein
bisschen Schokolade rein bisschen Butter
währenddessen das quasi hier anfängt vor
sich hin zu schmelzen können wir schon
mal die Eier nehmen ihr bräuchten jetzt
noch mal einen kleinen Schneebesen Maxx
dann hält zucchero Baiser Schlagen von
Hand nein erstmal nur die Masse zusammen
dann ein bisschen Mehl mit freigegeben
ein ganzes Ei okay jetzt mal ganz
ehrlich mit euch ne weil so Kochvideos
ich gucke immer wieder mal so aus Rezept
und sowas und der Mann hier macht
einfach aus dem Handgelenk alles
zusammen werfen aber nur ein ganzes Ei
ein Eigelb bisschen Zucker bisschen Mehl
fertig wir finden natürlich das Rezept
zu dem ganzen hier auch in der Video
Beschreibung also ihr müsst jetzt nicht
alles auswendig lernen weil mitgucken
sondern schaut einfach rein der Kürbis
ist fast fertig das heißt ich habe ein
bisschen Zeit um euch den Sponsor das
heutigen Videos vorzustellen klar kennen
viele von euch wahrscheinlich schon wenn
nicht dann ist hier ein kleiner
breakdown klar ist ein digitaler
versicherungsmanager in dem ihr alle
eure Versicherung gebündelt einsehen
könnt ihr habt einen Überblick über
euren Versicherungsschutz und wenn Clark
merkt dass ihr für irgendeiner
Versicherung zu viel bezahlt dann machen
sie die ein besseres Angebot und wenn
dann noch irgendwie Bedarf besteht
kannst du auch mit dem Experten darüber
sprechen das ist die eine Sache aber
klar kann auch viel mehr eine
Versicherung bei der viele nicht wissen
was sie ist und warum sie gut ist ist
die
Berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung
statistisch gesehen wird jeder Vierte in
Deutschland entlang seines Berufslebens
einmal arbeitsunfähig die größten
Ursachen sind nicht etwa Arbeitsunfälle
sondern zu 31% psychische Krankheiten
dass man zum Beispiel an Depressionen
erkrankt und deshalb natürlich nicht
mehr zur Arbeit kommen kann und in
solchen Fällen wo man sich nicht gut
fühlt ist es natürlich sinnvoll zu
wissen dass man abgesichert ist dass für
das eigene Einkommen gesorgt ist und man
nicht wenn es einem schlecht geht
trotzdem zu arbeiten muss die Jünger ihr
seid desto günstiger ist auch der
monatliche Beitrag deshalb könnt ihr
euch einfach jetzt von Clarks Experten
berechnen lassen und ihr wisst was es
für euch kosten würde ganz wichtig das
ganze ist aber vollkommen unverbindlich
also wenn ihr euch das berechnen lassen
müsst ihr es nicht abschließen wenn
jetzt aber eh schon interessiert seid
dann habe ich noch eine Kleinigkeit für
euch wenn ihr nämlich meinen Code Max
pane benutzt dann könnt ihr wenn ihr
drei bestehende Versicherung hochladen
einen Gutschein über 45 Euro bei best
choice bekommen man muss also keine
neuen Versicherung bei Clark abschließen
kann sich aber unabhängig und vor allem
kostenlos beraten lassen beim Hochladen
eurer Versicherung an Clark gebt ihr
einen maklermandat ab das heißt wenn ihr
bisher schon einen Versicherungsmakler
habt dann verliert der sein Mandat und
klagt hat euer neues Mandat also nur
dass ihr das auch ist deswegen vielen
Dank fürs unterstützen dieses Kanals
weitergeht ich mache was immer Du mir
sagst du kannst den Apfel schälen und du
kannst in der Nacht sage ich mal in so
groß war ein bisschen kleiner als den
Sellerie schneiden okay in der
Zwischenzeit nehmen wir uns den
Apfelsaft geben den in Topf wir nehmen
jetzt kein Zucker mehr weil ich finde
süß ist das schon alles genug und eine
Apfelsaft enthält ja auch von seiner
Natur aus Zucker eine kleine Idee Zimt
so schokolade und Butter sind gleich
geschmolzen kann das gleich in die Nähe
eine Mischung holen ich habe jetzt hier
ein bisschen Speisestärke die ruhig mal
kurz an warum anrühren wenn man
Speisestärke quasi jetzt einfach in eine
Flüssigkeit geben würde die heiß ist
würde sie sofort getrunken deswegen
einfach einen kleinen Schuss Wasser
drauf anrühren und fertig so wenn wir
jetzt mal einmal hier reinschaut das
haben wir hier sage ich mal ein bisschen
angedickt das ist jetzt eigentlich von
der Konsistenz eine Idee zu dick aber es
kommt noch weiße Schokolade rein die
macht's noch dicker aber dadurch dass
der Apfel ja auch viel Flüssigkeit
enthält okay wird es nachher eine Idee
wieder dünner es sieht schon fast ein
bisschen aus wie Karamell so ja es du
riechst auch wirklich hier schon den
Zucker dann einfach die Schokolade
nehmen wie sie ist
kriegst du sowas wie
sowieso sieht richtig gut aus
Süppchen von weißer Schokolade und Apfel
er weiß er weiß wie gut es ist das ist
möchte fast sagen es ist dumm gut alter
Schwede in der Zeit können wir aber hier
unser Küchlein fertig machen oh ja was
ist denn unser Teig das ist unser Teil
das ist unser Teig ach was das was ich
da am Anfang zusammengerührt habe was
ich dir das einmal hier reinlaufen und
du kannst das dann in der Zeit oh gut
aussieht
sofort an es wird fester aber das sieht
geil aus alter so und jetzt können wir
das mal hier in zwei Tassen aufteilen
wie schön sich das da reinlegen und dann
einfach ca so eine Stunde zwei schon in
Kühlschrank stellen das quasi die Masse
wieder fest werden kann wenn man das
jetzt warm Backen würde würde sich oben
drauf eine Fettschicht bilden weil die
Schokolade quasi abhaut und ich das kalt
stellen immer geht es einmal komplett
und es funktioniert nachher so ein
Hitzeschock dass das Fett nicht mehr
austreten kann kurze Zusammenfassung was
wir alles haben wir haben eingelegte
Zwiebeln wir haben eine Gemüsebrühe wir
haben gewürfeltes Gemüse eine weiße
Schokolade apfelsoße das heißt es kommt
alles langsam zusammen als nächstes
rösten wir ein bisschen Brot an dafür
habe ich schon die Pflanze bereit wie
dick schneide ich davon am besten ich
würde mal sagen so Finger dick ist gut
kleiner dick und auch gerne ein bisschen
schräg hat ganz einfach den Grund desto
mehr Auflagefläche haben wir nachher
natürlich auch ne ja ja klar dann
schauen wir uns mal unseren Kürbis an
boah das sieht schon gut aus ne fahr
einfach ich habe gar keine Zeit und
morgen muss das total schnell gehen kann
das auch super easy vorbereiten
einfach hier und das auch jetzt wirklich
sehr rabiat machen so runterhacken wir
bräuchten einen Topf über das Risotto
ansetzen können wir das können wir schon
mal parallel machen wir fangen an
Olivenöl eigentlich der klassische
Italiener gibt er jetzt auch Zwiebel mit
rein wir lassen mal Zwiebeln bewusst Weg
denn wir haben schon da Vorspeise
relativ viele Zwiebeln und wir wollen ja
nicht das abends das so ein Geschosse
wird von irgendwelchen Gasen unter der
Bettdecke das Risotto Korn ist ja ein
Stärke lastig das heißt bei Temperatur
öffnet es sich und bei Kälte zieht es
sich zusammen das heißt wenn man es
jetzt quasi am Anfang seid währenddessen
wir das Reis ein bisschen anders rösten
kann quasi das Salz in das Korn
eindringen und wir so wir Salz nicht nur
die Soße drumherum okay Thema Weißwein
das ist jetzt eine Sache die haben wir
offen im Kühlschrank stehen wenn man es
nicht hat muss man also klar wir sind
ein Budget dann nimmt man ein Stück
Wasser
braucht man kann direkt mit der
Gemüsebrühe anfangen man kann auch wenn
man hat irgendwie ein bisschen
Zitronensaft nehmen wenn jetzt jemand
sagt das gern keine Ahnung orientalisch
fancy passionsfruchtsaft uns geht's
einfach hier extrem um die Säure es
fängt außen an glasig zu werden das
jetzt in der richtige Punkt jetzt einmal
laut zwischen medial voll ja ist okay
wichtig ist jetzt bei dem ersten Schritt
den Alkohol einmal komplett verkochen
lassen und geben jetzt quasi auch schon
jetzt unser Gemüse mit rein aber auch
richtig also da merkt man jetzt auch das
ist schon eine ordentliche Portion also
wie gesagt wenn man sagt irgendwie das
sind da irgendwie drei Leute die jetzt
nicht so den größten Hunger haben kriegt
man damit auch locker drei Leute sagen
und jetzt immer nach und nach die Brühe
drauf geben nicht am Anfang alles damit
wir quasi immer auf unseren gewünschten
Garpunkt kommen könnten den wir haben
wollen bei dem Risotto jetzt da krass
ihr merkt also kurz einmal durchatmen es
geht hoch her heute auf jeden Fall aber
wenn man sich wirklich mit den Sachen
auseinandersetzt ist alles gut machbar
und was wir nicht vergessen dürfen auch
bei all dem was hier abgeht das ist
unter 10 € pro Person
denn ich finde das Biest jetzt gerade
richtig großartig und jetzt kommt jetzt
kommt die Rate zerflöten uns hier
einfach so ein bisschen duater halt
immer gamechanger ne die schmelzen wir
quasi noch mal an oder wie ja so richtig
schön creamy das ist so da drüber läuft
nur so ein zwei Minuten und dann essen
wir das jetzt einfach während die
anderen Sachen vorbereitet genau
quasi so ein so eine cooking Session
jetzt kann man sagen Energiekosten etc
pp weil wir brauchen es für unsere
Bruschetta wir haben es für unseren
Kürbis gebraucht vegan unseren Fisch
drin und wir backen jetzt
schokoladenaufbau also wenn man den Ofen
anschmeißtemperatur finde ich dann
sollte man ihn auch nutzen und das hält
auch noch fünf sechs Minuten durch wenn
es mal warm gerührt ist da muss jetzt
irgendwie nicht vom Tisch aufrennen hier
die musst du Braten so rufen ein
bisschen Olivenöl drüber seit gerne ein
bisschen Thymian warum sieht das so gut
aus
Achtung und derzeit den Fisch rein jetzt
kommt die Ziege los bin einfach mal so
frech und übernehmen das ja bitte ich
könnte es auch aber heute noch Basilikum
Basilikum machen gleich noch ein
bisschen Pfeffer Olivenöl drüber das
hier sieht so edel aus finde ich diese
einfache eingelegte Züge und die ging
sofort
fertig
[Musik]
wow also wirklich bildhübsch erkennt man
sofort ist eine brusketta aber in der
Form habe ich noch nie gegessen ihr
vielleicht auch noch nicht mir fragt
euch wahrscheinlich genauso wie ich wie
schmeckt das jetzt hier glaube das geht
richtig ab aber ich probiere mal
boah ich hatte Sorge dass wir das Brot
zu knusprig gemacht haben ist aber Todes
wichtig es ist schon fast so kostini so
ne so richtig richtig knusprig der
Kürbis ist von der Creme geworden aber
knüpft perfekt die bruskette an die
Säure von den Zwiebeln mit dem Essig
perfekt frische Tomate Basilikum
facettenreich ohne Ende sieht hübsch aus
und ist glaube ich die perfekte Vorspann
das passiert halt immer was wenn du
dabei bist also hast mal ein bisschen
süße ein bisschen Säure dann hast du
vielleicht mein hartes Stück dann hast
du vielleicht irgendwo eine kühle Tomate
dagegen also der Kopf arbeitet die ganze
Zeit und währenddessen du das genießt
mache ich mit dem Risotto weiter weiter
man sieht das hier noch in der Hand das
noch so eine ganz kleine weiße Spitze
vom Reiskorn ist und das ist jetzt der
Punkt wo der Italiener sagt das ist
altes ist wo wir quasi ein bisschen die
Hitze quasi fast gegen Null nehmen
einfach nur eins damit nicht auskühlen
und jetzt kommt rein du kennst es
mittlerweile von mir max die leicht
Linie Januar kurz noch mal zum Budge ne
Parmesan wenn man ihn neu kaufen muss
blöd man kann natürlich auch einen
anderen Hartkäse reinreiben aber wir
brauchen nicht viel davon deshalb für
Nudelgericht hat man häufig auch
Parmesan zu Hause wenn es gar anders
geht was man auch machen kann ist alten
Gouda nehmen aber ist halt da nicht mehr
ganz original oder wenn man es halt ein
bisschen leichter mag ja so Philadelphia
aber dann aufpassen bei der Butter bitte
allgemein waren das vielleicht 15 Gramm
Parmesan nicht viel jetzt haben wir
quasi das Risotto fertig unser Fisch ist
fertig jetzt haben wir noch den Rucola
beim Rucola machen uns eine ganz ganz
schnelle Nummer Fische schon fertig
sechs sieben Minuten der Backofen war ja
vorgeheizt beim Rucola machen wir uns
ganz einfach weil es ein bisschen Farben
vor haben noch ein bisschen würzig
nicole hat ja wunderschöne Senf Noten an
sich die Nüsse
nicht irgendwie hacken oder so viel zu
kompliziert einfach in der Hand
verstoßen dann haben Sie auch noch
unterschiedliche Größen und sie werden
von außen etwas grobporiger das auch
nachher wirklich schön Essig und Öl dran
hängen bleiben Öl wird jetzt rein ja
sehr gut
dann noch dazu als nächstes können wir
nämlich eigentlich schon direkt
anrichten du kannst jetzt klar gerne
einmal hinstellen jetzt habe ich schon
in der Zwischenzeit unten einmal unseren
schokoladenauflauf platziert das heißt
wenn du gleich verkürzt kann ja schon
mal weiter backen falls es nicht gemerkt
hat Max ist nicht mit der kocht all
diese leckten Dinge mit uns aber fast
gerade auf Kohlenhydrate ja richtig
miese Nummer richtig
lasst uns probieren Gemüserisotto Lachs
und ein kleiner Salat Walnuss Rucola
sehr sehr geil ich gehe einfach mal rein
ich mache es wie es dir gedacht hast
nehme von allem ein bisschen was ich
glaube gerade das macht ihr den Reiz aus
wir haben den Crunch von der Walnuss ich
bin sehr auf den Fisch gespannt und ich
glaube das wird ein richtig gute
Komposition probieren
schmeckt so gut vor allem so gesund
irgendwie obwohl der super viel Butter
drin ist Parmesan drin ist aber wir
haben halt wirklich auch nicht allzu
viel Risotto Reis verarbeitet man
einfach sagen kann so ja für das gute
Gewissen kann man das ja genauso
nachmachen
ja stimmt aber wirklich die
verschiedenen Konsistenzen auch hier
sind wieder das was wo die Raffinesse
ausmacht also dieser frische Rucola
wirklich lecker
[Gelächter]
das wirst du lieben Bro wirklich ist es
bitte mir fehlt auf jeden Fall nicht
mehr zum großen Glück ich bin wirklich
schon fast satt aber um richtig
glücklich zu werden fehlt mir gleich
noch ein Schokoladentörtchen und das ist
jetzt fast fertig gebacken richtig schön
aufgegangen und sieht wirklich hübscher
[Musik]
der große Moment wir probieren oh unser
Törtchen in der Mitte noch ganz weich oh
Mama von dir perfekt ausgelöst ja von
dir alles andere perfekt macht ich
probiere noch
und geht für zu Hause oder boah es ist
wirklich so lecker bisschen Frucht
bisschen süß ein bisschen Crunch
bisschen Säure und durch dieses flüssige
in der Mitte vielen lieben Dank dass du
dabei warst ich glaube wirklich jeder
der Lust am Kochen hat macht das am
besten nach weil unter 10 € pro Person
unglaublich leckeres Menü und es hat
sehr viel Spaß gemacht deshalb danke
schön bis zum nächsten Mal wir sehen uns
ciao